a qué se debe esta cifra récord
registrada el lunes
bueno buenas tardes estamos viendo este
movimiento migratorio desde hace unos
meses no es algo nuevo para el reino
unido lo que sí estamos como notando es
que se incrementan los números en el
verano algunas fuentes atribuyen esto a
pues a las condiciones de cruce del
canal que son más favorables para los
para los barcos pero este sería un
enfoque muy limitado pues si estamos
viendo que aumenta el número de personas
entonces si está este tema en las
agendas de francia y reino unido- y más
allá de francia la unión europea
entonces es un sistema es un es un tema
que involucra tanto a los gobiernos a
los estados como redes de emigrantes que
se aprovechan de la necesidad de estas
personas de escapar su lugar de origen
pero las autoridades indicaron que la
cifra de migrantes que han llegado
irregularmente se ha duplicado este año
en comparación con los primeros 8 meses
del año pasado cuáles son las causas
para este aumento si sabemos por ejemplo
que el gobierno lanzó una iniciativa
para deportar a ruanda a migrantes
irregulares y tratar de disuadir este
movimientos migratorios
así es los números están aumentando
incluso en estos días salió un reporte
del parlamento británico que hablan de
60.000 llegadas en el año que supera
casi tres veces lo que se lo que se
registró el año pasado entonces si es un
hecho que están aumentando las razones a
ver si uno consulta al gobierno
británico ellos atribuyen a este aumento
al tema de las redes criminales
alrededor de la inmigración ilegal y les
argumentan que aumentan porque están
cerrando la ruta y que están
aprovechando para este espacio para
llegar al reino unido- estas redes pero
al mismo tiempo proponen una política de
disuasión que es la que convención a que
es enviar a los solicitantes de refugio
a ruanda pica una medida que ha sido muy
polémica que aún no simplemente porque
está en revisión de la corte suprema no
podemos olvidar un puño ellos querían
tener su primer vuelo no pudieron
hacerlo por una decisión de un tribunal
europeo pero los candidatos a la hacer
primer ministro del reino unido a ambos
coinciden en la necesidad de retomar
esta medida entonces
y veremos seguramente un gobierno
conservador británico que se mantiene en
esta en esta media para atacar las
causas que según ellos son estas estos
temas ilegales sin embargo sí es cierto
que se llama la composición de los
migrantes a inmigrantes especialmente
del medio oriente de irán de irak
y esos países siguen en una
inestabilidad y en unas presiones
después de su régimen trial y usted ya
lo estaba mencionando pero qué
responsabilidad recae sobre el gobierno
francés y sobre el resto de la unión
europea en medio de este alto flujo
migratorio
y claro los migrantes salen en su
mayoría de puertos franceses del puerto
del caldeo alrededor de cali entonces
francia en ese sentido tendría cierta
responsabilidad en la medida en que debe
controlar las salidas sin embargo es
pues ésta está este tema pasa por las
tensiones políticas acá entre los dos
los dos gobiernos tanto del lado de la
mancha entonces el gobierno británico
por ejemplo la atribuye a estancia creo
a usa francia o señala francia de de de
ser muy flexibles muy laxos en el
patrullaje sus costas por ejemplo o en
contener la migración desde él desde la
salida entonces si hay una amenaza decía
hay una responsabilidad claramente
porque participa como un lugar de salida
pero pero digamos que la política juega
y mucho y se acusan mutuamente